can i start by
asking about what can only be described
as a truly extraordinary statement from
your old department foreign office
alleging that mr putin plans to install
what amounts to a puppet regime in
ukraine
what evidence do you have for that well
look the uh foreign secretary and the
foreign officers have come out
making it clear
what the designs of the russian
government are we of course don't go
into things like sources but it's very
clear there is a concerted not just
military buildup on the border but
threat to the
democracy the integrity of ukraine and i
think the the important point to note in
all of this is it's building up slowly i
think uh president putin and moscow have
had this habit of trying to take
advantage of opportunities when the
world's attention is perhaps elsewhere
and the foreign secretary is quite
rightly pointing to the designs that
russia has and we're saying really two
things first of all ukraine is a free
country under international it should
decide its own fate uh we will support
them in defending themselves
but also to the international community
european nato allies the us we're
standing shoulder shoulder saying
there'll be very serious consequences if
russia takes this move to try and invade
but also install a puppet regime okay
well if you know all of that you've
obviously prepared for the possibility
of that puppet regime and what are you
going to do about it well we
wouldn't telegraph all of the measures
that we would take but it's uh
important that this very clear message
not just from the uk but from all nato
and other interested
countries around the world who want to
uphold the rule of law that they'll be
very serious severe economic
consequences and of course ukraine will
defend itself
well it will obviously involve a range
of financial and economic sanctions we
wouldn't telegraph those
in advance what you can rest assured uh
is that the foreign secretary of the
foreign office
and the defense secretary will be
liaising with all of our partners
engaging and we have been doing so uh
for many months to make sure
that the response is robust and
concerted at the same time of course
what we really want is to get this
message so clearly to moscow that
president putin walks away from the
brink that is the off-ramp uh that we
would all like to see but let's let's be
concrete what what it actually would you
do for example
swiss bank accounts
well as i said i i can give you the the
the areas i'm not going to go into all
the details not only because that's
counterparty okay would that be one area
we would look at the personal interest
of vladimir putin and his friends in the
kremlin well we already have and you'll
remember i introduced magnitsky
sanctions to allow asset freezes and
visa bans to be imposed not just for
human rights abuses but also for severe
corruption all the tools at our disposal
whether it's sexual financial economic
sanctions but also individual targeted
sanctions uh are up for are on the table
and of course we we the the two things
that the kremlin care about are would
they get
locked into a quagmire in ukraine i
think there's a very serious risk of
that but also will they suffer an
economic price and and of course things
like nordstrom 2 and what the europeans
are willing to do on that is going to be
critically important in the hands of the
the germans and we don't know what
they'll do but i i'm very interested in
this point about um
the swiss and we know about magnitsky
but would you be prepared for example to
make the case for the russians to be
locked out of the international banking
system well i certainly think financial
sanctions properly properly targeted and
done in concert with our major partners
is something that we would readily look
at
is our government prepared um aside from
all of the word for an invasion of the
ukraine
and were there to be a an incursion
major minor whatever
what would we do would we send troops i
think it's extremely unlikely that we
would do that but what we have said is
that we are already willing
and engaged in training programs to
support the ukrainians defending
themselves that's absolutely right for
defensive purposes secondly as i made
clear we want to make sure that the
economic cost to the kremlin of doing so
is sufficiently severe that they think
twice what we want and the americans are
obviously engaged in the diplomacy liz
trust that foreign office are as well we
want putin to step back and realize how
damaging this would be for him let alone
for ukraine and the international
community okay before we move on i try
to ask you what might be a if you like a
personal question your
father fled czechoslovakia in 1938 yeah
uh after the munich agreement ahead of
uh hitler's invasion of the sudetenland
which most people now regard as a sort
of the paramount example of appeasement
that led to disaster
can you understand why this morning
people in ukraine might welcome your
words but still be absolutely terrified
that they will mean nothing to vladimir
putin
look i can uh absolutely empathize with
the plight of the ukrainian people i
think actually if you look at what civil
society and many of the
uh and indeed what the government of
ukraine is saying they're hugely
grateful for the forthright clear
sensible and calm but resolute response
that we've shown to them now ukraine is
not part of nato the self-defense the
collective self-defense provisions don't
apply but nonetheless it is a free
country that deserves to have its
integrity its direction
decided by its own people and we stand
shoulder to shoulder with them and all
other countries that want to respect for
the international rule of law in doing
so
this morning the former conservative
minister nazargani claims that her
muslim faith was cited as a reason for
her sucking it's a pretty serious
allegation
do you believe her well look i know
another and i've looked at that
allegation and seen what she said it is
incredibly serious let me just be clear
at the outset we have absolutely zero
tolerance for any discrimination any
islamophobia in the conservative party
and you'll be familiar with the review
that was conducted by professor singh
just on these specific allegations it's
very unusual but the chief whip has come
out and said the conversation concerned
was with him this is mark spencer and
he's categorically denied it in what can
only be described as the most forthright
and robust terms indeed as you said
calling it defamatory the one point i
would note is that i think if there are
any claims like this they should result
in a formal complaint which allows a
formal investigation to take place and
as the chief whip has pointed out amnest
hasn't made a formal complaint she was
asked to do so this
relates back to 2020
and in the absence of doing so
there would be no specific investigation
into this i get that but you're a lawyer
you're used to forensics
she says
he said this
he says
i didn't say it they cannot both be
right who do you believe yes but i'm not
going to get into that because i know it
gives the point yeah but but so trevor
you know what that gives is everyone a
headline was actually i want to tackle
the issue i think if there's any claim
like this a formal complaint should be
made and as the chief whipper said said
that niz was invited to make a formal
complaint she still is able to do so she
hasn't yet done so so i'm not going to
start getting into impugning anyone's
integrity that's not the business i'm in
i'm in the business of zero tolerance
for any islamophobia and
a claim like this as serious as it is
should be properly reported and then a
proper investigation okay so if she
makes that if she makes the uh formal
complaint you would favor a proper
investigation oh i think party i think
the chief whip made this clear back in
2020
all right
now look
this is just one more example i mean
on this particular thing it's it's
possible as uh someone wise once said
that recollections might vary but this
is just one more issue that's dogging
the uh conservative party we started
talking
uh by talking about ukraine nothing
could be more serious
uh or dramatic than threat of war that's
not an issue dogging the conservative
party but let me finish let me finish my
question yeah the point is that
um we have to deal with what you
yourself called the soap opera in
downing street and squabbles and
scandals this is pretty poor government
isn't it no i don't actually if you look
at this week trevor the two big issues
that will most affect people up and down
this country is the fact that our
vaccine rollout and the booster campaign
has been hugely successful the prime
minister got that right over christmas
and in the months before a major
decision and as a result we've got over
80 percent of eligible adults vaccinated
that reduces the that cuts the risk of
hospitalization by 88
and if we'd have listened to the labour
party by the way whose manifesto was
calling for the nationalization of
pharmaceutical companies who wanted us
pegged to the eu
your colleagues said that to me last
week i've got all well no but there's
people there's a big thing that's
happened this week's trevor if i may so
big decision prime minister got it right
kier has got it wrong it hasn't taken it
the other big thing is that we're coming
through locked down we're coming out of
those restrictions the economy fastest
growing in the g7 uh jobs are up wages
are up big call and back in july kistama
said it would be reckless so what i
would say to you when you challenge me
with poor the charge that the government
is a shambles and this that the other on
the two biggest decisions of the day
coming out this week it's topical prime
minister got it right because starmer
got it wrong yeah i didn't i did i
didn't use the word shambles i wouldn't
be so rude but my point is my point is
very very straight forward you might be
you might think this is the most
important thing indeed this program
which deals with these issues thinks in
these things are important but nobody is
talking about that what they are talking
about
when i knock on doors come on in the
pubs in
in isha that's what they're talking
about with their greatest respect i was
out campaigning uh last uh weekend this
weekend and actually people are asking
about jobs livelihoods the cost of
living is a big issue but of course if
we'd have listened to kia we wouldn't
have been out locked down and hold on
hold on hold on wages are rising so all
i'm just saying is let's have some
perspective all of that so have some
perspective because on the big issues
facing my constituents the your viewers
the country the prime minister's got
those big decisions right because
stamina has got them wrong yeah and we
talk about the big issues all the time
but let me put it this way some of my
colleagues would say
um you're a sky you keep going on about
these big things the only story that
matters and that we are hearing from our
viewers our readers and so on about is
the government's character the prime
minister's conduct let me put it to you
again yes i agree with you about these
big issues we we buy all of that the
problem is that you're as a government
paralyzed because you can't get past you
have to keep saying wait for sue gray
wait for that you can't get past that
issue yet well let me answer that
directly so yes of course it's the
distraction yes these are serious issues
yes uh must decide them uh in a very
serious way but i would say this week
we've shown that we are dealing with the
big issues that we haven't been
distracted because we're being able to
ease up on the lockdown measures that
only happens because of the success of
the vaccine rollout that only happens
because the prime minister held his
nerve when others including the labour
party were calling him to stay in
lockdown measures as a result fastest
growing economy in the g7
and unemployment coming down funnily
enough i mean just to give you a sense
of big picture unemployment is four
percent notwithstanding all that we've
seen in the pandemic that is half the
level that gordon brown who's coming on
your show left in 2010 yes
let's let's go there let's go to the
economy uh i agree with you it's the
biggest issue it is probably what they
are talking to you in the um
i don't know the weekly the prince of
wales whatever it is uh in your weekend
is my one of my local pubs there you go
in the wheat chief i bet you that
they're talking in between the gastro
meals that they're talking about these
things you used to tell us yep that the
governments that delivered runaway
public spending soaring inflation and
tax rises were labor administrations um
are you proud that your government's
delivered all of those things look i'm
proud that in the eyes of the worst
pandemic probably the biggest challenge
we've seen uh nationally probably
globally since world war ii
we've saved 15 million jobs through the
furlough scheme the vaccine roll-out
scheme has not just saved
thousands of life it's the fastest in
europe uh we're the most tested in
europe and as a result of that the
economy now uh is getting back to the
pre-pandemic levels fastest growing in
the g7 and we're providing not just
protection for the lives but the
livelihoods of people up and down this
country yes i am and actually i don't
take a theological view of these things
when you're in the eye of the storm of
the worst emergency we've seen a living
memory yeah but
you know you're saying we're coming back
to normal the economy install is good
but as i say
seven percent inflation public spending
soaring uh with the on housing uh energy
we're now going to see uh increases in
the proportion of our income spent on
energy because of rising prices for the
poorest 10 in this country housing costs
at 40 percent of their income is that is
that what the new normal is going to
look like
it's that thrilling it's a totally fair
challenge so
of course inflation is rising uh but it
will come down we're putting 12 billion
pounds of economic support in this year
extending the personal allowance is
something we've done an extra thousand
pounds for for all workers the taper on
universal credit means that two million
of the lowest paid will get
a further a thousand pounds the winter
fuel payments the um the the various
other measures we're dealing uh the
energy cap um
and all of those measures are there to
provide support for those uh on the
lowest incomes and who are feeling the
pinch but the one thing i wouldn't do is
nationalize the energy companies because
if you look uh which is what labour
proposed if you look at what the
confederation of british industry has
said that that would be hugely damaging
not just energy supply but it would hike
bills so again on the big issues we
under this prime minister under this
chance have got targeted measures at the
right calls in difficult times and
labour's approach will be an absolute a
disaster for for the very people you're
talking about you keep wanting to take
me back to the labour party that's fine
choices
trevor it's all about occupational
choices okay let me deal with that with
emily thornberry let's focus on you
my point that i'm really trying to put
you is we're faced with thread of war
economic storm brewing potentially by
the way uh collapse of the health
service because
uh all of the people who are not
vaccinated in health service going to be
sacked i don't think that's true i can't
i can't accept that oh well let's deal
with that yeah it is thought that 73 000
of their about health staff will be
sacked because they haven't been
vaccinated royal college of uh general
practitioners chair today says uh could
you delay this
otherwise health service is gonna fall
over what are you gonna do about that so
first of all there's a huge package of
support for the coverage recovery in the
nhs we've got nine out of ten nh staff
nhs staff vaccinated there's been a big
push to encourage vaccinations that's
really important it shows the progress
that we've made and we would encourage
anyone to come forward and get those
jabs before the deadline but we've also
got to think about the people who be at
risk if
if nhs staff don't have the vaccine and
just just on resilience we've got almost
5 000 more doctors almost 11 000 more
nurses than we did in 2020 precisely to
provide the support so i'm afraid i just
don't accept on the facts that challenge
all right well look before we finish i i
must just come back to this point you
know i've mentioned um we've met i've
never mentioned sue gray too much
because i know what you're going to tell
me we've got to wait for what she says
and so on but the point is
we understand her report's now going to
be laid because there are even more
parties to investigate she's going to
reinterview dominic cummings tomorrow i
understand
another red wall tory mp submitted a
letter of no confidence it really is
looking pretty grim for your government
your prime minister and this is more
than a distraction it is paralyzing you
well first of all accept the seriousness
of the issue that's why sue gray should
be able to determine who when and how
she investigates but i will point to the
decisions we made this week the success
of the vaccine rollout the measures to
open up the economy none of which would
have happened if we'd have listened to
the labour party all of which show
actually notwithstanding not your
absolutely and all of which show that
notwithstanding all of these other
issues significant as though they are
the pm is taking the right calls the big
decisions to lead us through the worst
pandemic in living memory